nous sommes avec nathalie attias
l'avocate présidente de la cee paris
avocats conseils d'entreprises bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors ce
soir à 19h30 le premier ministre edouard
philippe donc recevoir les représentants
de votre profession c'est une rencontre
que vous attendez avec impatience
alors c'est une rencontre qu'on attend
évidemment et on espère des signaux
forts de la part du premier ministre
parce que jusqu'à présent la profession
se sent totalement abandonnés notamment
par son ministre la ministre de la
justice qui est supposé être notre
protecteur comme elle a pris la défense
d'ailleurs des huissiers de justice qui
est également se sont mobilisés sur ce
projet de réforme
il faut comprendre que cette réforme des
retraites ce projet vient dans un
contexte très anxiogène pour la
profession d'avocat je rappelle quand
même que depuis
moi je fais du droit du travail donc
j'ai subi également d'autres réformes
mais nous subissons de plein fouet des
réformes depuis au moins trois ans par
exemple ont droit du travail on a subi
une réforme de la procédure prud'homale
et quelles réformes se sont succédé et
des réformes assez profonde nous avons
eu l'année dernière nous sommes nous
étions très mobilisé sur le pgl justice
la fameuse justice 21 et
jusqu'à jusqu'à cette année jusqu'à
décembre en ce début imposer des décret
qui réforme totalement la procédure
civile
on vit une révolution et personne ne
s'en rend compte
donc si vous voulez pour les avocats
c'est une angoisse dans leur exercice
quotidien puisqu'on doit intégrer toutes
ces nouvelles dispositions
et en plus de cette angoisse on vient
aujourd'hui nous dire voilà on va vous
imposer une réforme qui va conduire pour
les revenus sous quarante mille euros au
doublement des cotisations puisque
aujourd'hui nous sommes à quatorze
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais très rapidement et très
schématiquement 14% et en valais doublé
passée à 28%
vous imaginez que pour des revenus à
moins de quarante mille euros on va les
prélever du tiers de leurs revenus en
cotisations juste pour toucher une
retraite de base
aujourd'hui je rappelle que nous avons
un régime c'est ce que disait d'ailleurs
un des manifestants on a un système qui
fonctionne on a une caisse autonome
on a bien et ça je crois que vos
collègues les journalistes ont bien
compris la différence entre eux le
régime spécial qui était la dialectique
utilisé par le gouvernement et le régime
autonome donc nous on n'a jamais rien
demandé à personne
il pensait que ça se sera préservée
alors allez sur cette réunion ce soir
avec car il a le premier ministre hélas
je crains que non parce que si vous
voulez ce que l'on vit c'est aujourd'hui
un dogme de la réforme il ya un vrai job
de la réforme c'est à dire je veut
réformer pour réformer on a le sentiment
que on ne se pose pas la question de la
pertinence et là je crains hélas que l'
entrée dans régime universel est
d'ailleurs le premier ministre l'a dit
et le presque rien qu'en vous nous
expliquer c'est que cette réforme des
retraites c'est la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase absolue dans la
profession vous étiez nombreux hier à
battre le pavé avec les personnels de
santé d'ailleurs à paris le message que
vous allez faire passer que la
profession va faire passer à une part
philippe ce soir goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase ou pensaient que ce
message il va être entendu
alors ça le message est bien de vivre et
par nos instances 1 puisque
régulièrement le président du cnb et le
bâtonnier de paris
les avocats sont exaspérés 1 et
d'ailleurs on le voit on voit les ce que
font les avocats aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment du jamais vu battre le pavé
comme ce qui s'est passé et puis toutes
les actions qu'on a vu avec des
confrères qui dorment dans palais de
justice de bobigny par exemple est
d'ailleurs tous les barreaux de france
rivalisent d'originalité dans les modes
d'action et d'ailleurs est ce que votre
profession se reconnaît d'une certaine
manière dans cette grande social qui est
très large concerne pas seulement la
réforme de retraites on a vu évidemment
le mauvais landais gilet jaune aussi des
mouvements qui dénonce des arrestations
arbitraires une répression aussi
policière
ce que vous vous reconnaissez un peu
vous êtes solidaires de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en france alors je suis
totalement solidaire de mes confrères
contre ce projet de réforme qui est
mortifère pour les avocats et que les je
voudrais que les téléspectateurs qu'ils
nous entendent comprennent bien que
quand si des avocats disparaissent c'est
l'accès au droit qui disparaît savait
qu'il n'y a pas de démocratie sans
avocat on le voit dans le monde entier
quand les les démocraties sont en danger
c'est que les avocats sont rentrés en
première ligne c'est pas pour rien donc
si vous voulez je suis solidaire après
on peut être partagée sur les modes
d'action des confrères moi je n'ai pas
mon mot à dire c'est chacun chacun sa
conviction mais il y a quelque chose
d'assez unique et inédit c'est que tous
les avocats sont solidaires qu'ils
s'agisse des bas revenus ou des hauts
revenus parce qu'on ne le dit pas assez
mais les bars les hauts revenus vont se
voir taxer avec une cotisation
forfaitaire au delà de 100 à 1000 euros
avec aucune génération de droit ce qui
est absolument unique
quand on sait que cotiser à perte sans
avoir de droits en contrepartie c'est
profondément et qui est en outre ce
serait sûr que devrait peser la
solidarité parce qu'en dernière étape
des discussions c'est ce qu'on attend
c'est ce que le gouvernement attend de
la profession c'est que nous validions
le fait que ce soit les hauts revenus
qui payent pour les bas revenus
ça fait quand même plusieurs semaines
maintenant que
votre profession se bat pour défendre
ses droits en tout cas contesté cette
réforme des retraites avec d'autres
professions qu'il ya des manifestations
avenir professionnel
jusqu'où ce vous êtes près votre
profession est prêt à aller pour mener
ce combat jusqu'au bout
alors je sais pas si vous êtes vous
regardez un peu les réseaux sociaux bon
moi je vais j'y vais régulièrement je
vois beaucoup de groupes je suis dans
beaucoup de groupes d'avocats et je vous
garantis qu'ils sont très très très
mobilisé
honnêtement j'avais vu des confrères
autant chauffée à vraiment à blanc et
que le texte il est entré au parlement
oui le cabanon et parlement mais bon
vous avez vu dans quelles conditions
vous avez vu dans quelles conditions aux
avis du conseil d'état a trouvé que il
était regrettable que ce texte arrive
aussi vite parce que il y as énormément
de zones d'ombré puis il ya un article
dans ce projet de réforme qui qui est
dramatique c'est à dire et qui remet en
cause la confiance qu'on peut avoir dans
gouvernement c'est cet article 56 qui
prévoit que quoi qu'il arrive le ans je
ne sais plus exactement la date mais il
est prévu que si jamais malgré toutes
les modifications et tout ce que tu
scolaire a été négocié
si jamais on s'aperçoit que le kid
équilibre financier n'est pas assurée le
gouvernement pourra prendre part par
voie d'ordonnancé toutes les musiques ce
soir là une face à edouard philippe il
n'est pas question de céder moi ce n'est
pas du tout ce que je vous dis moi ce
que je souhaite mais c'est mon voeu je
ne suis pas convaincu que ce soit celui
de la profession moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est impératif que le
premier ministre accepte de discuter
mais avec des discussions globales c'est
à dire pas uniquement si do c'est à dire
vous voulez faire on veut des
compensations sur les augmentations de
cotisations mais cette compensation il
faut les voir ailleurs que sur le de
manière technique sur le régime des
retraites
je donne un exemple pourquoi ne pas
également discuté de la revalorisation
de l'aide juridictionnelle
par exemple ça ce serait un signe fort
qui sera envoyée aux avocats qui
pourrait permettre de sortir de la crise
merci beaucoup nathalie
à thiès je rappelle que vous êtes avocat
de présidente de la fce paris avocats
conseils d'entreprises merci à vous
merci